for the past few years we've been
calling men out it had to be done but
lately I've been thinking we need to do
something even harder we need as my good
friend Tony Porter says to find a way to
call men in my father began to sexually
abuse me when I was five years old he
would come into my room in the middle of
the night he appeared to be in the
trance the abuse continued until I was
10 when I tried to resist him when I was
finally able to say no he began to beat
me
he called me stupid he said I was a liar
the sexual abuse ended when I was 10 but
actually it never ended it changed who I
was I was filled with anxiety and guilt
and shame all the time and I didn't know
why I hated my body I hated myself I got
sick a lot I couldn't think I couldn't
remember things I was drawn to dangerous
men and women who I allowed actually I
invited to treat me badly because that
is what my father taught me love was I
waited my whole life for my father to
apologize to me
he didn't he wouldn't and then with the
recent scandals of famous men as one
after another was exposed I realized
something I have never heard a man who
has committed rape or physical violence
ever publicly apologized to his victim I
began to wonder what would an authentic
deep apology be like
so something strange began to happen I
began to write and my father's voice
began to come through me he began to
tell me what he had done and why he
began to apologize my father is dead
almost 31 years and yet in this apology
the one I had to write for him I
discovered the power of an apology and
how it actually might be the way to move
forward in the crisis we now face with
men and all the women they abuse apology
is a sacred commitment it requires
complete honesty it demands deep self
interrogation and time it cannot be
rushed I discovered an apology has four
steps and if you would I'd like to take
you through them the first is you have
to say what in detail you did your
accounting cannot be vague I'm sorry if
I hurt you or I'm sorry if I sexually
abused you doesn't cut it you have to
say what actually happened I came into
the room in the middle of the night and
I pulled your underpants down I
belittled you because I was jealous of
you and I wanted you to feel less the
liberation is in the details
an apology is a reading it connects the
past with the present it says that what
occurred actually did occur the second
step is you have to ask yourself why
survivors are haunted by the why why why
would my father want to sexually abuse
his eldest daughter why would he take my
head and smash it against a wall in my
father's case he was a child born long
after the other children he was an
accident
that became the miracle he was adored
and treated as the golden boy but
adoration it
turns out is not love adoration is a
projection of someone's need for you to
be perfect on to you
my father had to live up to this
impossible ideal and so he was never
allowed to be himself he was never
allowed to express tenderness or
vulnerability curiosity doubt he was
never allowed to cry and so he was
forced to push all those feelings
underground and they eventually
metastasize those suppressed feelings
later became shadow man and he was out
of control and he eventually unleashed
his torrent on me the third step is you
have to open your heart and feel what
your victim felt as you were abusing her
you have to let your heartbreak
you have to feel the horror and betrayal
and the long-term impacts of your abuse
on your victim you have to sit with the
suffering you have cost and of course
the fourth step is taking responsibility
for what you have done and making amends
so why would anyone want to go through
such a grueling and humbling process why
would you want to rip yourself open
because it is the only thing that will
set yourself free it is the only thing
that will set your victim free you
didn't just destroy your victim you
destroyed yourself there is no one who
enacts violence on another person who
doesn't suffer from the effects
themselves
it creates incredibly dark and and
contaminating spirit and it spreads
throughout your entire life the apology
I wrote I learned something about a
different lens we have to look through
to understand the problem of men's
violence that I and 1 billion other
women have survived we often turn to
punishment first it's our first instinct
but actually although punishment
sometimes is as effective it's on its
own is not enough my father punished
me I was shut down and I was broken I
think punishment hardens us but it
doesn't teach us humiliation is not
revelation we actually need to create a
process that may involve punishment
whereby we open a doorway where men can
actually become something and someone
else for so many years I hated my father
I wanted him dead
I wanted him in prison but actually that
rage kept me connected to my father's
story what I really wanted wasn't just
for my father to be stopped I wanted him
to change I wanted him to apologize
that's what we want we don't want men to
be destroyed we don't want them to only
be punished we want them to see us the
victims that they have harmed and we
want them to repent and change and I
actually believe this is possible and I
really believe it's our way forward but
we need men to join us we mean men now
to be brave and be part of this
transformation I have spent most of my
life calling men out and I am here now
right now to call you in thank you
okay okay
[Music]